president Trump commenting on the
coronavirus just moments ago as there
are now 62 confirmed cases in the United
States here's the president we haven't
lost anybody yet and hopefully we can
keep that intact week there have been no
deaths in the United States at all
the president also going after the media
much more on that later but first he's
looking to loom large over another major
Democratic primary he said for a big
rally in South Carolina in about two
hours from now
as Democrats prepare to face off in the
Palmetto State primary tomorrow the
Democratic Party splintering as
candidates continue to slam Bernie
Sanders and warn that his message of
socialism will doom the party's
prospects in 2020 I believe that if
Bernie Sanders gets the nomination he
will lose to Donald Trump he will make
sure that the Senate stays in Republican
hands he will flip the house back to the
Republicans and even down ballot he's
going to hurt the Democrats the fact
that someone lists himself as an
official independent not even a Democrat
except to run for the office of
president and then lists himself as a
socialist that doesn't fly but Bernie
remains defiant on it all we are
building a movement that cannot be
stopped and when millions of people
stand up and fight back nothing on earth
can stop us meanwhile Joe Biden is
looking for a game-changer in South
Carolina
strong polling in the state is putting
Biden in a good position but his
campaign is still plagued by more gaffes
Biden fessing out that he was never
arrested in South Africa while trying to
meet Nelson Mandela Mandela when I said
arrested I meant I was not able to I was
not able to move cops
afrikaners would not let me go with them
made me stay where I was I guess I I
wasn't arrested I was stopped I was not
able to move where I wanted to go we're
gonna get to all of it I do want to play
this sound for you though from james
Clyburn and the congressman from the
South Carolina who endorsed Joe Biden
this is what he had to say about Bernie
Sanders I was in Texas about three weeks
ago where there the Panisse Johnson
doing the bank prep for her
I talked to the faith community down
there and they were very very concerned
about whether or not you'll do something
I have somebody on the ticket that will
cause down-ballot carnage it's
interesting that they're talking about
down ballot carnage now Greg after
Bernie Sanders was in pole position to
win in Iowa and then in New Hampshire
and then in Nevada South Carolina he
might not do that well but pulling the
panic alarm now seems a little bit late
this is the big lesson that we've talked
about again and again that the Democrats
had for years to prepare for this moment
and to beat this orange demon apparently
the worst human that's ever lived and
what did they do they were like instead
of studying for the exam they decided to
play for tonight in their underwear
they chased these phantoms of
impeachment and collusion and an
obstruction and what and instead of like
devoting their intellectual energy to
actually finding a candidate or figuring
out a way behind the scenes whatever to
deal with Bernie
I think the Dems have you know they
always talk about voter suppression they
should worry about voter depression
because when you look at that ad that
field it is so flawed the field is so
flawed that you're not looking for a
voting booth you're looking for a bridge
and you're not gonna go so I I don't I
think that like there are gonna be a lot
of people that just aren't gonna vote
because this is just gonna be like you
know what people have Trump for another
four years we could deal with it in 2024
life goes pretty fast and now they're
gonna have all of these ads Jesse that
show somebody like a congressman Clyburn
saying that the down ballot consequences
of Bernie Sanders would include carnage
yeah Bernie didn't have a good week I
think his Cuba comments and then his
math not adding up on 60 minutes and
then at the debate really made people
think again what they're doing and
that's why Democrats are rattled but Joe
needs a big win in South Carolina
because he's kind of running on fumes
and his coalition really is soft he was
supposed to be the guy that was going to
win white working-class voters and he's
gotten walloped by everybody in the
field on those issues on the first three
primaries and he's supposed to turnout
Hispanics and he lost by 30 points to
Bernie in Nevada with Hispanics he only
beat Bernie by
10% with blacks in Nevada so he's not
even spending any money in Super Tuesday
he's only spent 600,000 long Super
Tuesday
Bernie has spent 15 million Bernie has
twice the amount of standard Bloomberg
has many backs hundred million dollars
they're here Geraldo I want you to
listen to Joe Biden talking about how
South Carolina could actually be kind of
a starting point for him let's listen to
that mm-hmm I've been deeply involved in
this in this community in this state and
I feel very good about it felt good
about it from beginning it's been a
launching pad for Barack and I believe
it being a launching pad for me South
Carolina does punch above its weight in
terms of these early states because it
gets to be crunch time when you get
there and I think that people are under
estimating the impact South Carolina
will have on the Biden candidacy I I
believe that he will win decisively and
that will change the conversation the
question is will anybody be focused on
politics when we really only care about
public health right now public health
and politics are the same story right
right and what people want to know is
how would you deal with they don't want
to see Biden sniping at Trump right now
they don't see Bloomberg sniping at
Trump they don't want to see politicians
I am deeply deeply distressed by what
Pelosi and Schumer did in attacking
Trump in and undermining the confidence
we have in our public health system this
is this is really really bad
but I think that Biden can pull off a
miracle here this is rocky he's a decent
person he's not my guy you know I I
would not vote for oh maybe I don't know
but I I I think that he will as a result
of South Carolina black people
specifically in South Carolina will
carry the former vice president across
the the finish line with the momentum
and that will affect Super Tuesday
even though as Jesse rightly points out
he spent about six cents okay
so just if I can um so african-americans
in South Carolina comprised sixty
percent of that democratic voting bloc
and the most conservative of that block
and in the past week we've seen Biden
leading on average between four and 20
points and
averaging 12 so you could argue that
it's his to lose but at the same time
did you guys see those two polls that
came out of CNN about from Texas in
California about Bernie oh yeah
like by a million 21 points in
California and nine in Texas so you
could argue Biden is saying oh that's
gonna be my launching pad but will
momentum launching pad that will it will
a momentum be enough for afterwards when
we're going to Super Tuesday with Bernie
looking like the bleep king of them Greg
yeah I believe that South Carolina will
affect those numbers you're right about
Texas in California but because it is so
close two days later yeah it moment
South Carolina the news all be South
Carolina's out there then in Super
Tuesday yeah I think you I do want to
ask Greg one last question about two
people that were on tonight Elizabeth
Warren yes mayor Pete Buda judge people
judge who actually did come in second in
those two contests but we haven't you
kind of like don't talk about him like
what's going on there without with those
two well he's got to go back to school
because you know school starts but you
know summer east he's gonna be a
sophomore in high school you didn't know
that did you
I don't know I think people said I mean
there's a lot of ego going on and why
people stay in these races it was the
same thing in 2016 it was hard to get
people out of the race you got to push a
man well a lot of rate a lot of
campaigns do not end because the
candidate wants them to it's because
they run out of money it's gotta go I
think on Wednesday you'll see this race
narrow here's a dumb question because I
don't know this if millions of people
are voting for Bernie Sanders wouldn't
they also vote for everyone with a D
next to their name that's what I don't
understand about that yeah I don't think
so some people go in and they split the
ticket a lot of both Sanders but you can
go in if you're a Democrat like 18 in
our Fox poll it said 18 percent of
Democrats said they would never vote for
Bernie or for Bloomberg so you could go
in and you could vote for your senator
and your Congressman and everybody just
leave that one well those people are
just crazy